a deal aimed at ending decades of
turmoil in chad the transitional
government and opposition have signed a
peace agreement but with one of the
biggest rebel groups refusing to take
part will this accord hold and if it
does how far off is democracy in the
central african nation this is inside
story
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad jim joom chad's transitional
military council has signed a peace deal
with opposition parties and armed groups
the agreement is the first step towards
democratic elections and a new
constitution many factions signed the
deal but one of chad's largest armed
groups walked out of negotiations when
its demands weren't met now the question
is whether the much
national dialogue will go ahead on
august the 20th jillian wolf has our
story
more than 40 opposition groups signed
the long-awaited peace deal on monday
giving them and the transitional
military council calls for hope it was a
very tough and difficult talks
but what is important is the result
which we got at the end of this loan
process
and i think that this agreement
will
lead us to
a seasonable peace in china
the deal comes after five months of
negotiations and could pave the way for
a return to civilian rule a cease-fire
general amnesty and a national dialogue
will be the first articles to be
implemented
the dialogue due to be held later this
month in the country's capital in gemina
is meant to lead to the formation of a
government of national unity
constitutional reforms and democratic
elections
qatar which hosted the talks says the
agreement is just the beginning so we
are very helpful that it will end
hostilities between the different
parties it will move the process from a
military process to a political process
and will allow for an easy transition
towards the negotiations in chad itself
a noticeable absence from the signing in
doha was the main rebel group the front
for change in concord in chad or fact i
think at the beginning
we were
a little bit sure that your factory will
not decide
chad one of the poorest countries in the
sahel has been locked in internal
conflict for decades
fighting among armed groups has forced
hundreds of thousands of people from
their homes
when muhammad debbie replaced his late
father as president last year he
promised political reform
and launched the peace talks that led to
the doha accord
over the years dozens of peace
agreements have failed but many here say
that after 60 years of conflict chadians
are tired of war
and ready for peace
for inside story jillian wolf
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests from the chadian capital in
jamaica we have ramaji hoinati a senior
researcher at the institute for security
studies in barcelona is enrique pico
director of the central africa project
at international crisis group and in
oslo is andrew yao chi senior researcher
at the norwegian institute of
international affairs specializing in
security issues in africa a warm welcome
to you all and thanks so much for
joining us today on inside story ramadi
let me start with you today
how many groups and factions ultimately
signed this agreement
how many didn't sign or participate and
do you believe that this agreement can
lead to a sustainable peace in chat i
think that in all we have around 50
groups that were
in the talks in dora
and up today we know that there was um
about 43 groups that finally signed the
agreement with the transitional
government and in the other side we have
around eight group that nine group that
didn't sign
this agreement
what we could say regarding the
composition of the different groups
those that sign although those that
didn't sign
within those that sign we have
some major
rebel groups like the ufair are laid by
erdly
we also have
the movement led by uh the general mama
nuri that's how within the biggest
groups that signed but in the other side
we have still uh the fact that is the
front uh for concord uh that didn't sign
uh the agreement and this is something
that
is worthy
to notice because uh we have to recall
that uh the last fightings in which uh
the president devi uh got killed were
opposing uh this very movement through
the national army and this is to mean
that the fact is one of the main
military
groups that are opposing to to that
regime so meaning
that
we have a deal
but as soon as one of the major group is
not part of this deal
we don't have this kind of general peace
agreement that have been expected from
the beginning
uh enrique you heard romaji there talk
about the fact that not all rebel groups
and factions uh signed this accord and
and one of the big worries is the fact
that the front for change and concord in
chad a group that is known as fact uh
that's the main rebel group that they
refused to sign this accord despite
last-minute efforts by qatar's mediators
the fact that they haven't signed the
fact that other groups have not signed
on to this how worrying is that
well it creates a lot of uncertainty
about the future not only of the
transitional process but about the uh
overall peace in uh in the country
um
we do have we always have to remember
that this piece deal has to be framed in
a much broader framework which is the
one of the transition
the
gathering in door and the agreement was
to be was supposed to be only the first
step
to bring rebel groups to the national
and inclusive national dialogue that is
supposed to uh start next week in
germany
so
the fact that one of the major armed
group has not signed this preliminary
agreement and will be not part will be
not included in the national dialogue in
the country uh is already creates the uh
the condition for border negotiation on
one side that may also weaken the
agreement that has been already signed
or
uh for a return to the to the rebellion
and for offensive or attacks as we had
in the past only last year
so it's still too early to say what are
the next step but it's sure that
something is already missed in the
national dialogue that is going to start
next week
andrew i saw you nodding along to some
of what enrico was saying so i'm going
to let you jump in but i also want to
ask you from your perspective um if if a
lasting peace is not achieved uh with
this accord how is that going to impact
other countries in the region other
countries in central africa
well i think for me the key challenge
here is that the even if you did have an
agreement that uh was met and it was
signed you would still need to be able
to implement the that agreement in
practice and that tends to be a
challenge with my african states now
regionally the challenge here that i
foresee is that it could continue to
spill over into other countries uh where
some groups have harvard uh i'm thinking
here of therefore as well in other
places where it creates uh sort of a
hospice for uh these groups to to hide
uh but also uh to play political
magazine between different states as
well so on the larger scale what it
could do
is create this continuous video regional
instability but also i'm thinking the
wider picture here is really about uh
chad's contributions to african security
we've seen a rise of chad over the last
decade uh particularly in uh larger
african missions i'm thinking of the
multinational joint task force in the
lake china base in the g5 so hell uh
even the um mission and so you know if
you're having security at home uh
eventually at some point these troops
could be sent back uh to deal with the
insecurity uh amongst the groups that
haven't signed uh and so the the wider
challenge or should i say concern for me
is that if this is not resolved or if uh
there isn't a meaningful uh process that
is put in place to try and bring some of
these groups that have said that the
nine groups have said actually no we
don't really pilot this agreement then
what happens there on that dynamic right
and so that is the space that we need to
be looking at as well long term here and
andrew you know since you brought this
up i mean when it comes to efforts in
combating armed groups fighting in the
region how significant a role does does
chad play in those efforts
well i think less so with armed groups
with more so with terrorists and there
are those on the panel who will be able
to talk to this mother uh but
particularly terrorist groups uh book
iran uh
lake chad basin and other groups as well
who are who who roam across uh
tri-border areas or the regional areas
uh that is a challenge but also chad has
been i i would say at the forefront of
trying to deal with with that uh
challenge uh particularly because other
states or member states of that region
within equals having always been uh as
forthcoming but also being equipped and
rapidly being able to deal with that
challenge so for me i think that is a
concern if
long term uh forces are then brought
back home to have to deal with this
challenge then what happens to this gap
we're already seeing this with the g5
sahel where for example mali uh mali is
pulled out from there you there's a gap
that needs to be filled uh again you
know chad has been under previous uh
leadership has been at the forefront of
dealing with this but this again if you
have this insecurity in in
internally which has always been there
to
say that but if it continues uh it could
mean that truths are deployed from one
area to the about to deal with that and
that long term isn't good for the region
uh enrique you mentioned a moment ago
that um this agreement is supposed to
pave the way for a national dialogue
which is supposed to begin in jemina
later this month um do you believe that
that timeline will actually be met that
this broader national reconciliation
dialogue can actually start
as it is scheduled to start this month
well
it's likely to be uh delayed uh again uh
i think because uh um even though uh the
uh committee to prepare the dialogue
works on the preparation uh since the
beginning of the of the year since that
well actually end of last year because
the dialogue was uh
originally
scheduled for january then delayed till
may and then reschedule on uh
the 21st
uh even though like the preparation has
been already long the
different
the contest has been also evolving in
the country so at some point some of
most of the city society organization
and the political opposition were
willing to participate into the dialogue
but then after the events in may the
arrest of the leader of
one of the
the main
opposition
coalition in the country and
also the uh discussion around the
attribution of seats about the quota of
uh the participation of the different
political actors uh in the national
dialogue this is
making the context and the situation
more tense and that an agreement hasn't
been found yet the political opposition
estimate and the civil society estimated
that out of the 1400 seats in the
national dialogue
1200
will be occupied by people close to the
government so a question about the
legitimacy and the inclusivity of the
dialogue is on the table since a few
weeks and this is not only about the
participation of the armed group or the
of the discussion in indo is something
much more
uh entrenched to the uh
inclusivity in the country and the
participation so this is something that
should be sorted out before the
beginning and it's unlikely that will be
done in only one week
ramaji um the front for change in
concord in chad that's the main rebel
group um they said in a statement that
their rejection of the agreement
followed the failure to take our demands
into consideration what kind of demands
are they are they talking about was this
simply about prisoners that they were
demanding to be released or was there
more at play here
oh uh there is more actually uh at stake
uh the the fate of the prisoner is part
of the demands they have but they were
also
having demands regarding uh the
transitional chart uh to mean the way
power is uh devoted most of the power is
devoted to the president of the
transition this is something they have
been talking about
there was also
the necessity for the people that are
actually leading this transition not to
be a candidate in the coming elections
it's something also that they have been
demanding they also requested a kind of
parity
in terms of our participants in the
encouraging title meaning there
shouldn't be more people that are close
or from
the former leading party or from the
transitional administrational council
but there should be a poverty in terms
of representatives so uh people from
that part but also
people from opposition parties from
civil society and also from rebel groups
and the last thing that they have also
been requesting and that is something
that we think uh can't be met actually
uh is uh the resettlement of the wealthy
world committee in charge of
organizing the dialogue if we consider
that a date have been set for that
dialogue meaning the 20th of august uh
it's in two weeks actually
so without how the government can still
you know reset the committee uh so i
think these are the main demands they
are doing
and
this is why also uh at the end they
didn't then sign this agreement and
won't be part of the rest of the process
uh andrew um one of the messages coming
out of the the conclusion of these talks
in doha was that
even for those groups who did not
participate this time out there there is
a hope or at least an offer being
extended by those who did participate uh
that they would like to see these armed
groups uh these rebel groups these
opposition figures participate at some
point going forward perhaps when this
national reconciliation dialogue finally
kicks off do you think that
you know is likely to happen will more
groups enter into this dialogue at some
point
that is my hope that that could happen
um i think it's crucial that that um
that offer be extended and continually
be extended uh why because if not like
as others have mentioned you then have a
non-inclusive approach uh which means
that you have these rebel groups who
continue to sit on the sidelines and
that isn't good for
the sort of the long-term stability of
chad and also other parts of the region
as i've mentioned before so for me i
think that that room and that gateway
should continue to be uh left open it
should be continuing to to uh
to to be dialogue should continue to be
used to open that gateway but i also
think what is also crucial is that uh
those who are leading the mediation
efforts and need to make sure that those
who have signed the agreements uh to
date uh meet their
stipulations and the protocols within
that agreement because it's not what you
then have a situation where these groups
who have signed end up rebellion and
then join in the groups who haven't
signed and then you have this for
further fragmentation of the agreement
itself and that long term as i have
spoken about in other cases like in
sagan and uh in south sudan isn't good
because then you can't consolidate the
the gains and and the peace that you
want to as well
enrique the transitional military
council uh had said um that it would
oversee an 18-month transition to
democratic rule uh and that elections
would eventually be held
have there been signs indicating
that they are actually going about
trying to organize elections
i will say that there is already a
general consensus more or less explicit
about the fact that the transition will
be extended the end of the 18 months
will be end of september beginning of
october and it's impossible that uh by
that date the national dialogue both the
national dialogue and the election will
be organized and to organize a credible
fair and credible election there is an
entire machine to be put in place
starting from the census uh then the
electoral commission etc that has not
been approached yet also because one of
the objectives of the national dialogue
is to
revise the transitional constitution the
traditional charter and to set the rules
for the upcoming election
chiefly about the fact if the member of
the transitional military council can
run
for uh in the upcoming election or not
so
uh the very basic rules of the games are
not in place of the game is not in place
yet and the preparation hasn't started
uh
the the champion government is still
looking for a funding for also for
international funding to uh support this
election but we are still far from that
ramadi from your perspective what do you
think is the earliest we could possibly
see elections happening yeah as uh erika
said
actually
the term that have been said for this
transition
normally the elections have to be
happening uh in uh the coming three
months but actually with that dialogue
that uh is just starting uh there's no
way having elections so within 2022 and
uh the earliest that the elections could
be organized in this country
might be around mid-2023 but again let
us recall the fact that evan for the
discussions in dover uh this debate
though have been uh lasting for five
months meaning that uh
there is no way someone can predict
exactly what could happen uh in terms of
hacking having the election so it's
meaning that the transition will be
certainly extended but then
we don't have any executive about
putting in place all the machine to
organize the elections as uh explained
by enrique so i think that mid september
mid 2023 is the more optimistic uh delay
i can set for this i could see for the
selections
and ramadi if i could also just ask you
i want to take a step back for a second
um is there
hope in chad right now among ordinary
citizens that this accord
could either stop or at least
significantly reduce any of the fighting
yeah i think that uh the world
transition process uh brought a lot of
hope here in the country but that also i
think about the fact that the people in
this country have been witnessing also a
lot of projects like this one a lot of
peace agreement between the government
and rebel groups that at the end of the
day uh turned back to instability in the
country so i think that with the
evolutions we are observing actually in
chad uh the hope that have been brought
about by the transition is kind of uh
fading away uh because of uh
disagreement we have we know that the
most important uh
rebel groups etc uh i think that
actually uh the feeling here in china is
very mixed in terms of hope at worlds
are turning back to the constitutional
order
uh enrique a moment ago you mentioned
how uh one of the steps that that is
believed that will be taken soon or at
least the plan is for it to be taken
soon is that a new constitution should
be drafted um how difficult will that be
to accomplish
well uh it will be
uh quite a difficult step to achieve um
first because uh first of all because
not all the parties as we just mentioned
will be represented in the national
dialogue so some
of the key uh military political actors
will not be part of the dialogue at
least this dialogue even though we hope
that there might be like a parallel
negotiation
but also because there is no agreement
on which kind of constitution
italians want to want to have during the
preliminary consultation
outside of the capital in germany among
the diaspora in the neighborhood
countries
that have been done in
around october november last year they
were very
hot discussion about the shape of the
state
a federation a unitary state so all
these issues will be on the table for
the first time actually in the recent
history of the country and there will be
a part of the debate beside all the
issues that we already mentioned about
the eligibility of the member of the
transitional government etc so
uh if it's properly done it is really uh
inclusive and representative the
national dialogue will will uh have to
work hard to frame the constitution in a
way that is accepted by all the parties
under the representative and enrique we
only have a couple of minutes left but
um how involved has the international
community been in reaching this new
accord and and how different is that
from other accords in the past
well the international community has
been facilitating the uh negotiation in
indoa alongside with the
qatari government
uh there's been a
mediator from france from uh from the us
from the african union indoor supporting
the negotiation but there has also been
pressure from the international
community uh towards the member of the
transitional
government i think mainly through the
declaration of this
chartered affair of the united states in
july
who called the transitional government
to change the charter and
and
do not run for uh for election
after the end of the of the dialogue so
they've been pressured in many different
ways
and the traditional government i would
say that is now in uh
now as to find a kind of balance
in between the pressure to end the
transition but also the fact that
uh his decision will not be perceived as
unilateral because this is one of the uh
one of the uh concern
of the one of the main concern of the
stakeholders involved that the
transitional government is now imposing
uh some decisions so we have a compared
to formal agreement and performance
dialogue we have an opportunity to uh
to move towards something that is much
more inclusive and legitimate but still
we'll see in the coming weeks or months
if there is a real willing to do so all
right well we have run out of time so
we're going to have to leave our
conversation there today thanks so much
to all of our guests ramadi uh ramaji
hinati and pico and andrew yaouchi
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammadan jerome and the whole team
here bye for now
[Music]
you